Ladies and gentlemen,
my first guest is known
for his subtle work
on the NBC show,
"Will and Grace"
please welcome,
Sean Hayes.
(applause)
♪believe it or not. ♪
♪ I'm walking on air. ♪
♪ I said I thought I could feel ♪
♪ So great. ♪
♪ Flying away ♪
♪ Oh we're gonna pray. ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Believe it or not ♪
♪ Its a... ♪
Sean Hayes everybody.
Thank you Sean
♪ Believe it or not ♪
♪ I'm walking on air ♪
♪ I said I thought I could feel ♪
♪ So great ♪
♪ Flying away ♪
♪ Oh we're gonna pray. ♪
♪ Ooh ooh ♪
♪ Believe it or not ♪
♪ Its a.. ♪
Yeah!
That was very nice.
How can I help you here?
( audience applause)
You're not coming out of this.
Here you go
wait, wait, wait.
Ha! Very nicely done.
Nicely done.
This way.
(audience applaud)
Sean that was incredible.
Thank you so much.
Sean that was,
that was many things.
That was dramatic,
that was expensive.
It also looked incredibly uncomfortable.
It was,
it was,
I'm kind of,
I just want to know the,
let you know the extra mile that I went
for you for that bit.
That's nice.
I had my testicle surgically removed
[Conan] Nice
And
So we have something in common.
Yeah!
(laughing)
And I just want to show you something.
Oh no no no.
Yeah.
Oh.
You're now looking at the,
at the inside of my body.
(laughs)
That's what I did for you.
That's horrific.
What did you do for me?
That's your own part.
Now Let's let's talk,
there's something important.
You,
you are from Chicago
Actually.
(applause)
You're a local boy, aren't you?
Yeah.
You know,
That's what you would.
Yeah that's what you would think.
I'm actually from Trenton.
(laughs)
You bastard, you lie.
Oh come on.
(booing)
No
come back.
I'm from the suburbs.
I'm from Glen Allen,
but I always hung out downtown huh!
Yeah!
(noises)
Go Glen Allen!
Cats.
Whatever they are.
That's sad.
One person there and
she was just was like,
(mimics cat noises)
No, you were, you were,
weren't you in a band here?
You were in a band.
Yeah!
Sounds From The Stairs.
(applause)
Exactly.
In the business We call that
pity applause.
(laughs)
You got a lot of that tonight.
Ah!
(bangs)
(kisses)
(licks)
I lick the snowball,
but now I have super powers.
(laughs)
So
yeah, I was
I was in a band that
clearly nobody's ever heard of.
[Conan] Yes.
And I was in it for five years,
right out of college.
And you know, I,
I played keyboards, which, you know, like,
the guitar is always
very very sexy instrument
playing the drums,
like the twirl, the thing,
you know like,
[Conan] You can really like on the guitar,
you can rock
It's like an extension of your penis,
the guitar,
Thank you.
But the
but the keyboards, the keyboard,
[Audience member] Keyboard suck!
(audience laughs)
Scott.
How does Scott feel?
(audience laugh)
[Conan] There we go,
more pity applause.
You know it's
That guy's not in therapy at all.
Yeah, no no.
Scott's going to be waiting
for that guy after the show,
he's going to be looking
through 3,800 people.
Who is he? Come on!
And that's going to have a guitar going,
dude you want to start a band?
So,
No, but you know,
there's nothing sexy about
playing the keyboard.
So I'd sit there and think like,
I was all cool
I got everybody to be in front.
I'd be like,
(imitates guitar)
(audience laugh)
You can't win doing that.
No that was horrible.
You have to compensate for like
shaking the ass a lot and
moving around.
Well maybe you do I don't.
Yeah yeah
Okay that's nice.
Do you miss this town?
Do you miss living in this town?
I do.
You know the thing that I miss most
about this this time of
the year in this town?
A barbecue
cause the food is the
best in the world here.
(audience applaud)
It's true.
(audience laughs)
There's like nine barbecues going on
in the studio right now.
(audience laughing)
Up there these people are just
cooking a whole pig up there.
(audience applaud)
They're just,
slowly.
No, but yeah,
growing up with the barbecues and stuff
and like
the thing I never understood as a kid
was people would be like, Hey,
come over for a barbecue
and be like, great.
It'd be like,
bring something to grill
and something you liked to drink.
And your favorite side.
(audience laughs)
And its like,
Well, I mean, do you want us ,
do you want me to bring the grill too?
And maybe build the deck to grill it on?
(laughs)
But I thought maybe I could use this
to my advantage out of college.
So I just constantly,
cause I had no money.
out of college,
I'd constantly have all these barbecues
and had people bring all the food
and I'd have groceries for four weeks.
[Conan] Yeah.
It sounds like a good it's
take advantage of people.
It seems like that's the
lesson you're teaching us here.
Yes.
Wow.
You're a really bad guy.
(laughs)
What do you do to screw with your friends?
Just get their credit
card numbers and screw it.
(audience laugh)
I'm more high tech. I'm like,
I'll destroy you.
(audience applauds)
No delete.
And now I'm just taking food.
You know, we got to take a break.
We'll have more of as a Sean Hayes.
Stick around.